معنى من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم ويتس
هيثم ما الجديد في هذه الاشتباكات
حاله من الهدوء الان تسيطر على الوضع هنا
في وسط الخرطوم وفي مناطق المحيطه
بالقياده العامه والمناطق التي ظلت تشهد
الاشتباكات المتواصله في هذا اليوم كان
اليوم بدا هادئا ولكن اندلعت اشتباكات في
الساعات الاولى من النهار وبالتالي
توقفت بعد ذلك بعد اكثر من ساعه وساعتين
من مرور هذه الاشتباكات ايضا الطيران سلاح
الجو تابع للجيش حلق في سماء الخرطوم في
عدد من مدنها في الخرطوم وفي الخرطوم بحري
وفي ام درمان وكان هناك يبدو اهداف لبعض
المواقع في الخرطوم البحري ويبدو ان
المضادات الارضيه ايضا ردت على هذا هذا
التحليق من الطيران التابع لسلاح الجو
وايضا في شرق النيل كانت هناك ايضا مضادات
ارضيه ترد على التحليق سلاح الجو في تلك
المنطقه الذي ايضا كان يعني يقوم بطلعات
جويه
مواقع التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع السمه
البارزه هي وجود الاشتباكات او المواجهات
العسكريه ولكن بدرجه اقل مما كانت عليه في
يوم امس نحن اليوم في اليوم الثاني من هذه
الهدنه السادسه ولكن تشهد يعني عنف اقل من
ما هو كان بالامس وبالتالي هناك شيء من
التفاعل بان تكون هذه الهدنه اقل هدوء من
الهدن الماضيه ايضا هناك حراكه شعبي
وسياسي يتفاعل في الداخل السوداني ونداءات
متواصله لضروره وقف هذا الاقتتال وهذه
المواجهات الداميه من العديد من الجهات
والكيانات الشعبيه والسياسيه والتجمعات
الحزبيه التي تدفع ببيانات متتاليه من اجل
حث الاطراف على ضروره وقف هذا الصراع
وبالتالي تحت فرصه لايجاد حل سلمي لهذه
المواجهات التي كلما طال عمدها كلما كانت
انعكاساتها اكبر خاصه على الجانب الانساني
الذي بدات تحذر منه المنظمات الدوليه
والاغاثيه
الاوضاع اصبحت يعني مزريه في كثير من
الاماكن الخطر يهدد العديد من المواطنين
في شان النقص الغذاء وايضا الخدمات
الاساسيه ويطالبون باتاحه فرصه وفتح ممرات
امنه للوصول الاعانات الغذائيه خاصه وان
بعض المنظمات مثل برنامج الغذاء العالمي
اعلن عن بدء استئنافه عن عملياته في
المساعدات الانسانيه في الخرطوم وبالتالي
هذا الوضع يحتاج الى الطريق اتفق الاطراف
على وقف اطلاق النار وهو ما ظلت تدعو له
الاطراف الدوليه التي تدعو الى
بالنسبه لطريق الخرطوم الفاشر ماذا يعني
فتح هذا الطريق
الطريقه الخرطومه الفاشر طبعا هو طريق
قومي يربط اكثر من ولايه مرورا بولايه
شمال الكردفان وولايات الدارفور والثلاث
وايضا ولايات كردفان الكبرى هذا الطريق له
اهميه اقتصاديه كبيره بالنسبه
للخرطوم للسودان باعتباره اساسيا يغذي
العديد من هذه الولايات او لكن هو كان
ايضا يعني طريقه تقوم به عمليات الامداد
لقوات الدعم السريع كما قال الجيش انه
الطريقه الذي ظل يكون مسار الامداد ولكن
فتحه من الناحيه التجاريه بكل تاكيد
سينعكس ايجابا لتحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
لكثير من المناطق المتاثره التي تعتمد في
امدادها سواء كان من العاصمه الخرطوم او
ولايه الوسط السودان الى هذه الولايات
التي تستورد او تستقبل الكثير من المواد
الغذائيه والاساسيه من العاصمه الخرطوم او
العكس من المواد القادمه من هناك وايضا
يسهم في حركه المواطنين الذين يرغبون في
مغادره الخرطوم في ذاك الاتجاه للاماكن
التي تعتبر اكثر امنا بالنسبه لاشتباكات
اليوم صحيح ان الوضع هادئ الان لكن كانت
هنالك اشتباكات هل هل هنالك اماكن جديده
هل فيها جديد ام هي تتركز حول نفس المناطق
التي كانت تتركز حولها مسبقا
بحسب البيانات الصادره لحتى الان لا يوجد
توسع في نطاق هذه المعارك وهذه المواجهات
ظلت المواجهات تنحصر في الاماكن التي ظلت
تدور فيها الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري ومحيط القياده العامه وايضا في
احياء بحريه الحلفايه وكافوري وحي شمبات
وايضا منطقه شرق النيل وكلها مناطق تنتشر
فيها هذه القوات وايضا في ام درمان الجزء
الغربي من ام درمان منطقه الصالحه التي
ايضا بها معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع اكثر
المعركه هي عباره عن هجمات جويه او ضربات
جويه لسلاح الجو ينفذها على مواقع تتمركز
فيها قوات الدعم السريع وحتى الان لم تشهد
التوسعا جديدا في هذه الاشتباكات لكن فيما
يتعلق باشتباكات الشوارع لا توجد الشبكات
شوارع
حتى الان لا توجد يعني هناك طبعا تحركاته
وارتكازات كما يقول الجيش في بياناته
واتهامته لقوات الدعم السريعه انها هتتخذ
من بعض الاماكن السكنيه دروعا بشريه
وتنتشر في بعض الاحياء وانها تحاول ان
تقوم بملاحقه هذه القوات ولكن قالت ان هذه
العمليه تسير ببطء لتجنيب المواطنين
الالتحام او الاضرار التي يمكن ان تنتج
النتيجه للقصف الذي يمكن ان يكون فيه
الاماكن المدنيه وبالتالي هذه العمليه
يبدو انها بحسب تصريحات لقاده الجيش في
اماكن في اكثر من مناسبه في اليومين
الماضيين ان هذه المعركه ستثير ربما ببطء
ولكن لتجنب حياه المدنيين للخطر وبالتالي
تنحصر في الضربات الجويه في الوقت الراهن
وايضا مع تنفيذ بعض العمليات النوعيه او
في المقابل الدعم السري يتهم الجيش بانه
يقوم بالقصف العشوائي في الاماكن السكنيه
وان ذلك ينتج عن المزيد سقوط المزيد من
بالنسبه للمدنيين الذين يقتلون في هذه
الاحياء اذا يعني هناك تمركز لهذه القوات
في بعض الاحياء وايضا لكن يعني تقل هذه
المواجهات احيانا وتشتد في اوقات اخرى
شهينا في اليومين الماضيين يعني عمليات في
داخل الاحياء البحري تحديدا في الشوارع
الرئيسيه مثل الشارع الانقاذ والشارع
المعونه وشوارع الشنبات كل هذه يعني
الطرقات داخل الاحياء السكنيه وكانت
الساحه للمعارك والمواجهات القويه والشرسه
ايضا في منطقه شرق النيل وايضا في ام
درمان في منطقه الفتيحاب ابو سعيد كانت
ايضا هناك مطاردات وساحه للمواجهات داخل
هذه الاحياء المواجهات لم تخرج من نطاق
هذه المدن طالما انها في المدن الكبرى
المدن الثلاث من درمان والخرطوم والخرطوم
البحري اذا هي تظل داخل هذه المدن المكتظه
بالسكان فيما يتعلق بما اعلنته الدعم
السريع من اسقاط طائره حربيه من طراز ميج
هل هل دعمت ذلك بصور لهذه الطائره
بفيديوهات هل هنالك رد من الجيش او بيان
يوضح ان كان ذلك حدث ام لا
حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يعني تريد قوات الدعم السريع المكان
تحديدا الذي قالت بانها اسقطت فيه هذه
الطائره هي الطائره من طراز مجد كما قالت
القوات الدعم السريع بحسب البيان وايضا
الجيش حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعلق على هذا
البيان ولم يرد وبالتالي يعني هذا البناء
المنسوب لقوات الدعم السريع وهو يعني حتى
الان تصدر اي بيان مرفق او فيديو مرفق
يوضح يعني ان كان هناك اشلاء لهذه الطائره
او مكان
لسقوط هذه الطائره وان كانت في احد مدن
الخرطوم الثلاث الخرطوم او بحري او ام
درمان ولكن اكتفت بالبيان انها اسقطت طائر
الصباح اليوم وقالت بان هذه الطائره ظلت
تقوم بعمليات قصد مستمره لمواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع في مواقعها المختلفه سواء
كان الخرطوم او بحري شكرا هيثم ويت مراسله
الجزيره من مكتبنا في الخ